what specific advice do you have for
Christian business owners and content
creators your morals should resonate
through the company you know like we
have our four core values core value
number one is serve others core value
number two is trained daily like get
better every day core value number three
is play fair have integrity core value
number four is no ego not everyone who
works for us as Christian
um they gotta have Christian values yeah
if they don't they can't work for us but
also you need to be the best example of
those values because nobody's following
you if you say hey follow these things
and then you don't do them